peu vu
[Musique]
nous sommes fabricant d'articles
érotique alors est ce que nous avons à
peu près 160 références aux quatre
anneaux
alors ça va effectivement depuis le tout
petit tout petit comme ça en passant par
le gros en passant par les moyens on
commence soit pas un moulage comme ceux
ci soient dans une sculpture
et on obtient une peau en latex en latex
naturel qui est extrêmement souple
extrêmement
solide et qui fermait qui est remplie
après soit avec une mousse soit avec un
matériel plus grosse part et d'autre
chose et ça marche bien en français
d'articles les gens ont maintenant
vis-à-vis des gadgets et vis-à-vis des
jeux sexuels une attitude beaucoup plus
libéré qu autrefois plutôt que
d'échanger x fois partenaire clé risque
ça constat l'heure actuelle on utilise
des gadgets pour redoubler sa sexualité
nous avons les contacts avec tous les
sections de fond ce que nous fournissons
bien sûr et également à l'étranger
maintenant
et puis aussi tous les gens qui nous
contactent directement en nous disant je
veux telle pièce particulière alors nous
les faisons la demande des choses comme
celle ci n'existait pas c'est un petit
string est extrêmement simple
extrêmement mignon qui n'existait pas il
y avait des choses qui était grossière
dur moche pour tout dire quelle est
l'importance du marché français nous
nous produisons et distribuons à peu
perd entre 3000 et 3500 pièces par mois
et nous y avons nous distribuons au
niveau du gadget à peu près 30% 1/3 du
marché c'est un marché qui sans être
secret quand même relativement fermés il
y a à l'heure actuelle environ 300
sex-shop en france qui sont nos
distributeurs principaux nous exportons
à l'heure actuelle en hollande en
allemagne en espagne
nous exportons les poupées aux états
unis et à hong kong et nous avons un
marché plus entre effet certainement en
début de semaine prochaine avec le
canada
[Musique]